una sentencia que tendrá que esperar el
24 de noviembre se conocerá el fallo
contra karim benzema el delantero
francés se enfrenta a 10 años de cárcel
en suspenso y una multa de 75 mil euros
esa fue la petición de la fiscalía que
lo considera cómplice en un presunto
intento de chantaje a su ex compañero de
la selección francesa mathieu valbuena
junto a otros cuatro acusados penn se ha
considerado el proceso como una farsa y
no se presentó en las audiencias sus
abogados cuestionaron a la fiscalía y la
justicia se presta al espectáculo el
fiscal teatraliza el caso desde el
principio
benzema no puede ser condenado porque no
ha hecho nada en algún momento pedimos
que se deje de lado la cara del
espectáculo y se concentren en la
cuestión de fondo
jussi con su cónsul fundirse los hechos
se remontan a 2015 cuando valbuena le
entregó su teléfono accedan go un hombre
cercano a los círculos del fútbol en
marsella y le pidió transferir sus
contenidos a un nuevo dispositivo
and go encontró un vídeo de contenido
sexual explícito que presuntamente
intentó aprovechar junto a su amigo
mustafa su guau y para la fiscalía ellos
se aliaron con otros dos intermediarios
y benzema para chantajear a valbuena los
acusados han negado la presunta
extorsión y utilizaron eufemismos para
explicar que querían ayudar al jugador y
ganarse su favor el abogado de valbuena
recibió con agrado la postura de la
fiscalía el hecho de que él sea
reconocido como una víctima y pueda ser
recompensado por daños y perjuicios es
fundamental para que pueda superar lo
que fue un calvario terrible nominado al
balón de oro benzema conocerá su
sentencia cinco días antes de que se
entregue el prestigioso premio